well I'm delighted to say that he joins
me now speaking for the first time since
Saturday's defeat all right well Dylan
how are you first of all feel great uh
MMA is a lot harder than boxing I'll say
definitely on the body MMA is yeah yeah
a lot harder yeah but you are wearing
dark glasses yeah there's a reason I
wear glasses all the time let's have a
quick look I don't want to get have
let's see the eyes there we are not too
bad I mean I was in a fifth fight but he
looked worse he was running the whole
time you know I wanted to fight he was
running so really get satisfaction
here's my take on what happened yeah did
you watch Fight You are yeah you are a
brilliant jiujitsu yeah fighter I mean
you're one of the best has been right
you're a world champion multiple times
you have huge credibility and respect
for everything you've achieved in
Jiu-Jitsu but when I watched what
happened uh the weekend um with you and
Logan Paul I just thought I don't know
it just feel seemed to me like what was
in that for you I get it makes you more
famous I get it made you a ton of money
I get all that I get from a marketing
point of view everyone thoroughly
enjoyed the Extravaganza but as a
fighter with a great reputation when you
came away from it what did you
feel about the fight the fight it didn't
feel like a fight feel like he was
running away every time I tried to
engage with him and try to get in there
and like trade he would run away you
know you landed nine punches in six
rounds yeah I mean but the thing that's
not great is it it's cuz he was running
though even Conor was saying it he he
was running he was he was on the back
foot the whole time I was trying to push
forward I wanted to fight I wanted to
clinch I wanted to fight I was like I
mean he threw more fights at the end
with the security guys that big dude man
I was trying to get out him but he was a
chunky big dude and he was pushing me
away and everything but it was why did
you just for the record why did you
suddenly dive in and do a Jiu-Jitsu move
I wasn't actually trying to but he was
smart he baselined his head his head up
so I guess he knew I was trying to go
for his neck but at that moment I
actually wasn't I was just grabbing his
head and he just kind of shrugged me in
the Vaseline and he threw that punch and
then I up kicked him but you dived in
for his body legs yeah I was just kind
oh that one time yeah I was just kind of
just messing around a little bit you
know let him know what the real fight is
um boxing is not a real fight it's a
half a fight I want to fight him in a
real fight where he shook my hand and
said he was going to fight me in MMA do
you think he'll ever get in an MMA
environment with you he shook my hand if
he's a real man he should you know um he
didn't defend his fiance in my opinion
if a man talks the way I did about your
fiance he should I wanted to mention
that too because I I don't know him or
his fiance Nina Agdal right but I don't
know I think that's her stage name is it
but isn't it a bit cheap dyl to go for
the girl not the man no because if it
was if it was someone else yes I would
never do that I would never cross those
lines with the Pauls they cross those
lines all the time um his brother went
at should you should you stoop to that
level um in this fight I think it it
made sense because it was all true
everything was public I what she saying
what she suing me for is all fake I
didn't hack her phone I didn't do all
any of you ever done that to a Jiu-Jitsu
opponent no no I would have done even
like if if I was talking about a regular
fighter's wife every would be like oh
the guy's well people know this
is true people know her past it's all
out there so everything was public and
you know what I mean though you're a
you're like I say you're a world
champion fighter just seemed a little
bit demeaning me to Target the woman not
the guy in a Bo in this boxing match
he's 0 and2 I'm a I'm a Jiu-Jitsu Guy
where we going to sell our our boxing
skills no you know I'm a promoter so I
wanted to make people watch this fight
and it did over 1.3 million views so how
much money did you make from it a lot
you haven't said how much yeah I don't
want to say the number but a lot of
money a lot of money but I should have
been theer I should have got the
pay-per-view and you did actually say
that if you lost you would give your
share of the purse we fact we got a clip
we never we never shook hands we never
shook hands a CLI yeah I bet knock you
out how much I don't care don't matter I
I made a bet to you what was it it said
if I win it had to be the best man at
you're winning okay okay okay and if I
win yeah I get your entire purse sure
sure all right well that's pretty unical
so Dylan hey here we have a large check
a large check May payable to Lo but what
we don't know we actually are making so
it actually might be a win for me
because he punched me on the ground so
the appeal might be I might be the
winner but if we were to put a figure in
here what do we looking at uh over a
million over a million pounds or dollars
dollars a million US Dollars yeah that's
your cut yeah I mean is that is that
your biggest ever payday in fighting yes
for sure yeah you know MMA doesn't pay
that well that's after this I'm going to
the UFC I want to go to the UFC I think
the UFC now will see my potential in
selling fights and everything like that
so see I that's that's the bit I get I
think you're a smart marketing guy right
this came up under the best yeah this
has all been a very smart marketing
player I get that uh I mean I went down
to see uh your mate Conor McGregor fight
Floyd Mayweather and it was a
fascinating thing to watch I never
actually thought he could beat Floyd
Mayweather but but for a few rounds he
went Toe to Toe with him and it was
really interesting watch and it was a
massive success financially for both so
I do get the exhibition kind of nature
of this but it's not real fighting is it
no it's not in my opinion it's not me
and you gone to a street fight we're not
going to be like hold a second let's go
get these gloves and throw it on and box
we're fighting and he knows I would
strangle him unconscious within 30
seconds in a real fight that's why he
didn't do the real fight in the real in
MMA the bag was bigger than the boxing
bag actually so he turned that down and
uh what would happen if you fought him
in MMA it wouldn't last more than a
minute how would you take him out I I
would play with him I could take him
down Mount him and literally slap him
around and just it it would be
embarrassing actually it'd be so fun do
you think any boxer funny enough I did
Celebrity Apprentice uh with Lennox
Lewis and Tito Ortiz the UFC guy but
these boxers think they good fight they
it was it was actually very interesting
so um we got talking one night because
every night you do these long hours
sitting there talking together and I
said what would happen with you guys and
I got them two sets of boxing gloves and
they sparred in the room right oh
definitely then and it was fun well they
both agreed that if it was straight
boxing Lennox would win yes right he's
one of the great world heavyweight
champions of all time but they also both
agreed that if it got into Tito's world
of UFC he would win because he would get
LX down and L exactly these guys don't
know what they're doing and Logan tries
to act like he would you beat any boxer
do you think all all of them I could
probably do it in the same night like
KSI Logan Jake I could probably do back
what about what about the elite boxers
actual easy easy uh the only one they
ever wrestled I think was terce Crawford
but I don't think he has like a serious
r background but the Jiu-Jitsu was too
hard to learn that's why these
influencer boxers they don't do MMA
because Mayweather his Peak oh easy you
would easy easy easy he has no he
doesn't have power the hard thing with
like the dangerous thing about a boxer
for MMA guy someone that has a one punch
shot we saw this in the first UFC's you
know once you shoot in it's over you
know you need to land that one shot and
it's very hard so once they get a hold
of someone it's over you know you you
weren't happy that Drake the rapper yeah
friends too that hurt me well he bet on
Instagram $850,000 on your opponent to
knock you out he lost yeah he lost cuz
he didn't knock you out yeah and me and
Drake were friends so I didn't like how
he supported Logan Logan have you been
in touch with him no he has a new number
now but uh yeah he he posted a story
saying like he bet against you he's
ghosted you what's going on there I know
it's messed up I don't know hopefully he
watches this he'll reach out to me well
what's your message to Drake if he's
watching um should have been on me
camera's there I don't know I thought we
were friends Drake that's messed up you
know Logan's not not one of us we don't
suit we don't do lawsuits you know Drake
is a gangster like me we don't do that
kind of stuff yeah yeah so I don't know
I think Drake would decide with me in my
opinion you know Logan's a i he's a
can I say that on here I don't
know you could we called unsensitive for
a reason okay yeah he's a you know
he he wanted to Su off this is this is
what he wanted he didn't want to fight
he wanted me to pull out this fight and
he learned it was real when he did that
water ball and he threw at me and I hit
him with that mic cut his face on but I
gave him almost like a concussion so he
knew it was real he knew what he he's
not a real fighter he's not a real he's
an Entertainer you know he's not built
for this is that good for the fight game
generally to have these kind of YouTube
influences I don't like it I don't like
it but you've taken part in it and it's
benefited you yeah because if you're
Logan PA you're like hang on a sec you
say you don't like it you just came in
and made yeah Logan fought Mayweather so
he has credibility but sometimes you go
around these events you see these like
Tik Tok kids walking around like they
can fight and I'm like come on dude like
it's kind of I don't like it either I'm
like come on and it's dangerous you know
boxy's not uh
a gentle sport you got to be careful so
like these like tag team things are
doing and stuff it's very dangerous what
would happen if you got in the ring with
Connor I wouldn't that's that's one of
my best friends I don't talk about
training Partners you know so have you
you've trained with him oh I trained
with him for almost 10 years how serious
hases he got oh he train uh Conor trains
very very hard and he hits very hard and
he takes it very seriously you ever ever
knocked him out no I would I don't see
like real martial arts don't talk about
training that's the thing about me and
these guys are different I'm a real
martial arts I've been training since I
was 15 and uh we go by the code of
martial arts you don't talk about train
would you ever fight him though no never
never that's you're Dan White you're
thinking now with all your profile I
think me and khabib or me and is on
would be bigger you know I mean
obviously Conor is one of my best
friends and the my idols and a mentor
you couldn't beat khabib could you no
one's ever be kabib I would beat khabib
but no one's beaten him yeah well he
hasn't fought me why would you better
able beat him because my Jiu-Jitsu is
too good and I I'm saying this now all
the stuff I've ever said I'm willing to
go prove it give me my give me any all
people look I'm not as expert as you are
and all the why jiujitsu is too good for
these guys I was going to ask you if you
are as good at jiujitsu as you are yeah
who do you most fear I don't fear no one
you know I I want to know what's going
to happen in your world look at me I
just went and did a boxing match in the
UFC for example what time of fights
would you least want to come up
against I I swear I would fight all of
them I would fight Jon Jones I'm not
scared I did a lot of detector you could
beat him I I did a lot of detector test
and it showed that I you know I believe
that and I think if you're a fighter and
you don't believe that then you're not a
real fighter you know I believe I could
be any man in the world so I think these
guys aren't that good and I'm willing to
go prove that so put me in the UFC and
give me Islam for a f so Dan White is
watching this yeah what's your message
to him sign me let's do it give me the
biggest fight give me anybody you want
just don't send anybody you want back
I'll beat them all um and I want to
prove what I'm saying is true because it
pisses me off that people don't believe
in me you know so I want to go out there
and I'll fight anyone of them well I I
I'll be honest with you I had to consult
my middle son who's a bit of an expert
in you he loves you oh he likes me yeah
and he said Dad don't don't get sort of
distracted by what happened with this
kind of thing that happened with with
Logan he said he is one of the greatest
jiujitsu yeah exponents in the world how
many Jiu-Jitsu guys were going and do a
boxing match right you know what I mean
that's what he said yeah and I went out
there I didn't get wobbled I didn't get
a standing a count every single one and
now you're 10 times more famous than you
were two months ago exactly and I didn't
do it for the fame um but you know I
thought Logan would be a better promoter
he was Terri terrible at it I carried
this whole promotion on this card better
than Tommy they better than KSI they
didn't give me any pay-per-view points
they treated me like everything was
against me the steroids that he was
taking he was taking EPO um the refs
were on his side he picks the refs he
picks the judges he picks everything you
know so I was a handicapped the whole
time he still he still beat you then
yeah but I don't he beat me in a boxing
fight right you know so if he beat me in
an MMA fight but even that's a b
embarrassing isn't it Kevin no be he's a
YouTube influencer he he box for five s
years he could have rattled me he was
trying to say he would knock me out in a
second every MMA guy Joe Rogan he's
going to get knocked out in a minute
he's going to get knocked out like this
look what happened to Ben Asen he didn't
do anything to me you know made a couple
smacks do you think do you think he'll
ever get in the Jiu-Jitsu world with you
or MMA never no I don't think I mean he
shook my hand see how much of a b he is
so I'm ready to do it I can do it
tonight I didn't take any damage so I
want to take a fight in the next 30 days
I'm ready to go Dylan dnis good to see
you good to see you fighting talk you've
actually committed yourself to about
eight fights there realize that I'm down
for it let's do it I'm ready to go I'm
ready to fight right now so whoever
wants it let's go I'll be there if you
do good to see you good to see thanks
for coming in
awesome